let me see oh you fly dog hey
what's up everybody it's julius randle
of the new york knicks and after an off
season back home in dallas i'm excited
to be back here in new york city and
right now we're about to check out a few
spots with a little help from my wells
fargo active cash visa card it helps me
earn unlimited two percent cash rewards
on purchases let's go
[Music]
over here at pickle guys about to try
out a bunch of different things i'm
excited let's go check it out what we
got what we got i'm a foodie man so this
is like right up my alley let me do the
pineapple try this one
you like it i'm gonna try the garlic
yeah i like garlic too my wife don't
complain about my breath after this
what's your favorite
asparagus
bro
he don't even like veggies
brussels sprouts
it's good this is a good it's a great
experience man
i appreciate you brother thank you and
enjoy absolutely i'm out here extra
butter doing some shopping kicks clothes
shoes a bunch of dope stuff in there man
[Applause]
you wear the clothes the clothes came
where you so whatever it is i got to be
comfortable in it i definitely would say
i'm the best dressed on the team for
sure i'll just do my own thing and just
kind of let that you know speak for
itself people were the high-end brands
and stuff like that but you don't have
to do that to be stylish and fashionable
man
you asked me my two man shoes that i
wear nike you gotta go forces
gotta go air max i got all the flavors
bro
[Music]
appreciate it you find everything okay
yeah you guys got some great stuff in
here
man just want to check in and say what's
up to some fans what's up bro first and
foremost lifelong knicks fans so
thank you for turning this thing around
i appreciate you bro man that's love man
we go out every night we compete as hard
as we can but you guys are energy man
you guys are the batteries where's
anybody on the knicks that's going to
surprise us next season you think just
talking to tibbs and you know every day
having a conversation with him he's
really excited about our rookies i
appreciate you guys all the fans and
in here checking it out appreciate y'all
appreciate the love
uh
and i'll see y'all soon when i'm out
i'm here at on may with kaiden himself
about to go look at some toys shop have
a little fun we'll get some baby brother
get something for his little brother too
so we're excited let's go check it out
what should we get for baby brother
should we get him this hat
yeah
this one or a red one oh a red red one
oh the red one zoom huh hey
why
that's nick's blue right there boy you
can wear that to school man what about a
book buddy okay
[Music]
there you go
good job
[Music]
today i had an absolute blast hitting
some great stores but i actually love
the fact that i got to earn two percent
cash rewards on my purchases today with
my wells fargo active cash visa card
i'll see you guys later